[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
après son tête à tête avec vladimir
poutine emmanuel macron poursuit son
marathon diplomatique à kiev qu à berlin
le président français a dit avoir obtenu
de poutine qu'il n'y ait pas de
dégradations ni d' escalade mais moscou
dément la russie a envoyé six navires de
guerre en mer noire à kiev emmanuel
macron a proposé de reprendre les
accords de minsk dans le cadre du format
normandie le président ukrainien a
confirmé son attachement cessez le feu
le président français maintenant
discussions avec alive shoals et le chef
d'état polonais duda dans la capitale
allemande alors l'ukraine devra-t-elle
faire des concessions emmanuel macron
joue-t-il le rôle de good cop quand les
états unis auraient celui de bad cop le
président français peut-il obtenir une
réponse collective face à la russie
enfin va-t-on vers une désescalade pour
en parler j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés j'appris cnic bonsoir jacques
jacques rupnik directeur de recherche
émérite à sciences po spécialiste de
l'europe centrale bienvenue dans le
débat également michel duclos bonsoir
bienvenue à vous également diplomate
conseiller spécial à l'institut
montaigne nous avons avec nous par skype
d'antibes igor delanoë à bonsoir
directeur adjoint de l'observatoire
franco-russe bienvenue à vous
également par skype de washington cette
fois michael chow kane directeur
programmes internationaux au 14 mars
strategist bonsoir à vous
aimer mais le maquereau et volodymyr
zelensky ont donné une conférence de
presse cet après midi à l'issue de leur
entrevue à kiev le président français
dit croire à des solutions concrètes
pratiques pour aboutir à une désescalade
de la crise ukrainienne on écoute le
président français puis le président
zelensky on ira tout de suite à kiev
retrouver notre envoyé spécial james
andré la russie
en adoptant cette posture menaçante a
décidé très clairement de mettre
pression sur la communauté
internationale
j'ai eu l'occasion hier d'en parler
longuement avec le président poutine et
la démarche que j'ai engagées en ne
rendant à moscou et à kiev vise
précisément à
restituer collectivement or
stabilité et sécurité sur notre
continent est mise à mal par cette
pression militaire croissante
je crois pour ma part qu'il y a des
solutions concrètes
pratiques qui nous permettront d'avancer
n'utiliser aucune de ces formules
et vous ne m'avez jamais entendu dire le
mot que vous avez utilisé pour ce qui
est de l'ukraine je n'ai d'ailleurs pas
fait de comparaison j'ai dit que mettre
fin à la politique de portes ouvertes de
l'otan serait un problème pour plusieurs
états européens dont la finlande et la
suède par exemple et je n'oublie jamais
je me suis jamais rentré dans ce type de
formule que vous venez d'avoir
conformément aux accords conclus lors du
sommet de paris en décembre 2019 nous
attendons à pouvoir tenir très
prochainement les négociations entre les
dirigeants des pays les formats noir
la première réunion a été très réussie
nous attendons avec impatience une
deuxième réunion dans les prochains
jours
nous espérons que la réunion du 26
janvier et les futures discussions à
berlin nous rapprocherons de la tenue du
sommet du format nantes
retrouvez notre envoyé spécial james
andré à kiev james et qu'est-il ressorti
concrètement de cette rencontre macron
zelensky
bien écouter ce qu'il en est ressorti
d'abord c'est qu emmanuel macron a
martelé une nouvelle fois son
attachement au processus de minsk c'est
ce qu'il avait également dit à vladimir
poutine se tait l'un de ses objectifs de
réellement revitaliser ce processus de
mise car leurs conseils dans quelques
jours il y aura une nouvelle réunion
format normandie de s'assurer bien que
les deux chefs d'état étaient bien
d'accord pour aller de l'avant emmanuel
macron l'a dit il faut avancer sur ce
processus et il faut évidemment se
rendre compte que et pour volodymyr les
hélices qui notamment un qui était à ses
côtés aujourd'hui et qui a réaffirmé
devant les journalistes à volonté
d'avancer sur le processus de minsk ce
n'est pas chose facile pourquoi ce qu'il
y a plusieurs lignes rouges et puis des
difficultés politiques au niveau du pays
parmi les lignes rouges il ya la volonté
de ne pas dialoguer directement avec les
séparatistes pro russes qui opère dans
les territoires de louhansk et de
donetsk également il y à la nécessité
d'organiser des élections dans les
territoires qui ne sont pas actuellement
réellement sur le contrôle de l'état
ukrainien aussi il faut une modification
pour appliquer intégralement les accords
de minsk de la constitution ukrainienne
autant de mesures extrêmement
impopulaire ici qui sont très difficiles
à mettre en oeuvre qu'il va falloir voir
comment les choses évoluent il faut voir
aussi bien sûr que la russie a elle même
sa propre façon d'interpréter ces
accords de minsk par ailleurs il y a eu
également des avancées selon le
président français sur les bases d'une
nouvelle organisation de la sécurité des
traités au niveau européen il ya un
petit cafouillage semble-t-il avec le
kremlin par rapport à ce qui a été
avancé ou non le kremlin dément
certaines des choses qui ont été
avancées mais en tout cas emmanuel
macron nous dit que effectivement il a
obtenu la garantie auprès de vladimir
poutine qu'il n'y aurait pas d' escalade
supplémentaire également que vladimir
poutine s'était engagé à ne pas
envenimer la situation
donc le président français parce que
vladimir poutine a dit durant la
conférence de presse il a dit que les
idées françaises pouvaient servir de
base à des négociations à venir mais
pour l'instant on ne sait pas
précisément exactement ce que le
président emmanuel macron a mis sur la
table durant ces cinq heures de
discussions avec vladimir poutine et
puis bien aujourd'hui ça a été deux
heures et demie avec zelensky donc des
échanges nourris profond en profondeur
qui selon le président devrait permettre
d'ouvrir des négociations d'ouvrir des
portes et des possibilités pour une
désescalade dans la région ajoute deux
choses intéressantes parmi les sonneurs
que vous avez précisé il y avait le
président d'un cran quand il disait les
mots que vous utilisez et s'était
répandue est une question d'une consoeur
sur la finlandisation mais n'a pas voulu
lui même dire le mot dans sa propre
bouche et puis dernière chose voli de
limur zelensky a dit n'avoir pas regardé
la conférence de presse conjointe entre
macron et poutine disant qu'il était
trop occupé merci pour ce résumé james
james hendaye en direct de kiev jacques
rupnik il a nié mais la lumière croit
avoir utilisé ce terme de finlandisation
de l'ukraine à l'issue de cette entrevue
avec avec zelensky est ce qu'est ce que
ça signifie la finlande la
finlandisation de l'ukraine que
l'ukraine pourrait devenir un état
tampon entre la russie et l'occident oui
la finlandisation resserré c'est le
modèle finlandais disons de l'après
guerre ou en 1945
les soviétiques auraient pu annexé la
finlande et les alliés n'aurait sans
doute pas branché et n'ont pas fait la
finlande avait une autonomie sur le plan
interne était aligné en politique
extérieure disons autre en politique
extérieure c'était ça et donc
accommodante vis-à-vis de moscou c'était
ça le modèle de la finlandisation donc
vu d'europe de l'est d'ailleurs c'était
pas ce n'était pas quelque chose
d'infamant c'était au contraire
considéré comme comme un acquis
extraordinaire parc aujourd'hui c'est
utilisé par contre utiliser dans le
contexte ukrainien c'est exactement
l'inversé d'hier c'est vous vous essayer
d'appliquer la doctrine de la
souveraineté limitée à un pays qui est
indépendant souverain et qui devraient
pouvoir choisir librement c'est à dire
que ce soit en face à la russie enfin
c'est à dire
autonome sur le plan interne c'est ça la
finlandisation mais dans en politique
étrangère à voir certaines lignes rouges
pour ne pas déplaire au grand voisin de
l'est michel du coup ça a été tout de
même à débat cette phalange isation de
l'ukraine alors là emmanuel macron dit
qu'il n'a pas utilisé le terme il ya un
débat en ce moment sur justement spes de
statut de neutralité de l'ukraine ce qui
serait une très forte concessions de la
part de l'ukraine si elle acceptait
d'abord il faut dire des choses très
simplement s'il doit y avoir une
évolution du statut des ukrainiens ça ne
peut être que nous le crâne ça ne peut
être que les ukrainiens qui qui le
décide donc de la part d'eads et des
observateurs extérieurs où des
puissances étrangères il ya quelque
chose d'un peu malsain mais on voit
qu'il ya un souhait qui a une idée qui
est dans l'air si vous voulez alors les
uns utilise cette expression de
finlandisation l'eau d'autres de
neutralisation je n'ai pas pourquoi on
ne se réfère jamais au traité d'état
autrichien pourrait être aussi un modèle
mais il ya beaucoup de gens pour qui ce
sera une porte de sortie élégante win ce
serait le cas ou pas est-ce que le crâne
est un peu mise au pied du mur
aujourd'hui michel duclos après après
cette espèce dans cet entretien qu on a
vu une très belle macro et le président
de l'ars qui oui il ya une certaine
ambivalence effectivement dans les
démarches des occidentaux
le fameux format normandie il a quand
même mérite c'est de mettre les crânes à
la table des négociations
sans ce format on discute de lycra une
partout mais ça on le sent les
ukrainiens et donc
je je je pense qu'il faut pas tomber à
bras raccourcis sur ce sur ce
set enceintes en même temps c'est vrai
que quand on dit il faut que minsk
avance fois qu'il ya des progrès faut
qu'ils aient des concessions de part et
d'autre ça veut dire il faut quelque
part que les ukrainiens bouge donc on a
pas l'impression d'une sorte de on force
un petit peu l'ukraine à faire des
concessions igor delanoë est ce que
c'est un peu votre sentiment d'abord
cephalon 10 à sion de l'ukraine si elle
avait lieu à ce que ça devrait
satisfaire vladimir poutine
écoutez sur le terme de sonorisation
joue un petit peu ce qui a été dit avant
c'est à dire que c'est pas un statut que
vous décrétez pour un état à l'itc cet
état qui décide à un moment donné lui
même de renoncer à certaines
orientations politiques étrangers rafale
le de finalement garantir sa sécurité en
tout cas ce qu'il estime être sa
sécurité donc c'est pas un statut vous
pouvez crocheter de l'extérieur et dire
du jour au lendemain on va vous
neutraliser donc si on s'en tient à une
fois de plus à à l'origine du terme
maintenant sur ce que deux oui en
réalité il y avait vraiment très nouveau
depuis le départ c'est le seul cadre
sérieux qu'ils considéraient pour
résoudre la crise dans le temps passe
maintenant la question est celle de la
mise en application des provisions
politique est aujourd'hui comme c'est à
dire être appelé c'est très clairement a
du cran de bouger et d'avancer dans la
mise en oeuvre littérale dans l'ordre où
cela était libellé moins dure la formule
steinmeier qui te permettent
d'intervertir 2 provisions mais pas au
delà pour l'instant de mettre en oeuvre
c'est ces accords concrètement c'est
réforme constitutionnelle on va y
revenir longuement à la fin de
l'émission parce que pour l'instant je
voulais rester un petit peu justement
sur le concept de fall en dise à sion et
faire réagir avant de reparler des
accords de minsk en reparler michael
sheen encore une dernière fois sur cette
idée de finlande isation de l'ukraine
qu'est ce qu'on en dit aux etats unis
dès cette idée
c'est très bien vu cette idée je crois
qu'on était très critique en croyant que
mac os 1,10 à on a dit que ce sont tes
de capitulation et ici en étirant 706
c'est une équipe de la france va tout
seul devant des concessions et imposer
des concessions sur l'ukraine je crois
que c'est pas de dudka que c'est pas du
tout vrai mais mais mais il faut lui
dire que
les gens ici sont assez sceptiques cela
ton petit de mâcon et donc ils sont
sensibles cette idée de capitulation de
concessions forcé mais il faut admettre
que ce que mc on essaie de faire c'est
très difficile il essaie de trouver un
équilibre entre la nécessité de parler
de la quasi impossibilité d'avoir une
solution diplomatique
il faut aussi donc je l'applaudis parce
qu'il faut que quelqu'un comme a
commencé assez mais il ya si peu
d'espacé de manoeuvre pour pour les
parties vous tuez d'une revue d'études
et côté que c'est bien difficile à
savoir imaginer une solution en dehors
de faire des concessions et ce serait
des concessions que en se posant va
imposer à l'ukraine on va écouter bruno
le maire pour voir ce qu'il a dit ce
matin justement nos confrères de france
inter
ne nous laissons pas entraîner par les
américains sur une position qui ne
serait pas celle des européens les
européens ont grâce notamment présent la
république une position indépendante
dans cette crise ukrainienne des
intérêts différents de ceux des
américains et il faut pourra le dire à
nos alliés américains de la manière la
plus claire nous avons des intérieurs
avec différents de ceux des états unis
dans cette crise nous la voie que nous
privilégions ça n'est pas celle de
l'affrontement ça n'est pas celle de la
menace c'est celle du dialogue et la
désescalade jacques rupnik est-ce que ml
macron c'est un peu le good cop dans
cette question ukrainienne et les
américains joe biden le bad cop oui on
peut voir ça ainsi il y a
ceux qui parlent fort et qui
menace d'utiliser toute une série de
mesures sanctions
armement des ukrainiens etc etc et de
l'autre côté le président français qui
en tant que président de l'union
européenne de la préside et en la
présidence tournante de l'union
européenne va à moscou et à kiev pour
essayer de voir s'il ya de la place pour
un pour un dialogue donc oui il peut y
avoir ce partage partage des rôles je
crois que cette idée que qu'est une
grosse division
d'opinion que ce que vient de dire le
maire je ne suis pas certain d faso sur
le fond ce n'est pas le cas il y à des
divisions bien sûr d'appréciation et de
méthode au salon et au sein de l'europe
bien entendu si le président macron est
aujourd'hui à berlin c'est aussi pour
parler au chancelier allemand et au
président polonais et bien sûr que
l'épaule si vous demandez aux polonais
et aux baltes ce qu'ils pensent de la
ddt de la crise ukrainienne bien entendu
qu'ils pensent que les mesures fortes
des mesures essentiellement dans le
domaine de la sécurité sont essentiels
si vous demandez aux allemands eux ils
mettront plus tôt l'accent peut-être sur
la nécessité d'un dialogue le on a vu
hier dans la conférence de presse entre
byden et le chancelier allemand
byden avait dit si il y à une invasion
de l'ukraine c'est la fin de notre
structure est menacée par le chancelier
allemand qu'il l'a dit c'est le
président américain donc il y as oui il
ya en ce moment un dialogue entre alliés
et ça c'est une excellente chose et un
dialogue entre européens si on doit
reconnaître au moins un mérite à cette
initiative française on ne sait pas sur
quoi elle va déboucher mais c'est
d'avoir remis l'europe au au coeur du
jeu politique parce qu'on avait eu la
rencontre de genève entre poutine et
dylan et tout le monde disait c'est
incroyable l'europe est absente l'europe
est impuissante là on voit que l'europe
est de retour et tout le monde parle du
processus de normandie le minsk et c'est
donc les européens sont de retour par
contre les américains et mais peut-être
que les américains ne sont pas
mécontents que les européens eux mêmes
se charge de ce dossier parce que leur
priorité numéro un c'est la chine c'est
le pacifique ils ont d'autres et la
crise l'ukrainienne d'une certaine façon
c'est une distraction par rapport à ça
cette priorité principale michel duclos
vous êtes d'accord est ce que vient de
dire je suis à cryptic je suis
complètement d'accord je ne pourrais pas
l'avoir aussi bien formulée mais pour ma
part ce que je vois c'est au fond une
partition commune aux puissances
occidentales américains et européens
dans cette partition commune se sait pas
ce que dit bruno le maire oui mais
distingué au contraire non mail approche
diplomatique française et c'est vrai que
la une du washington post et hier était
encore sur les cinquante mille futures
victimes qui seraient liés à une
invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
enfin bruno bruno le maire s'est
s'exprimant en politique et peut-être
que c'est logique de sa part de de
mettre en relief les différences mais
autant canalis je crois que en réalité
c'est la même partition qui est joué par
les différents acteurs avec des accents
différents donc ça rejoint votre idée de
good cop bad cop mais si vous voulez
quand bruno dit
nous on est différent parce qu'on est
pour la
le dialogue la d escalade
le président américain est également
pour le dialogue et la désescalade bien
entendu est par ailleurs ce sont les
français qui ont le premier les premiers
utilisé l'expression de conséquence
massives en cas d'agression russe sur le
crâne donc je ne crois pas qu'il ya une
très grande différence d'à proches et
vous savez ces hommes d'état qui se
rendent à moscou avec qui se concertent
entre eux et c'est ça me rappelle
beaucoup ce qui s'est passé au moment de
la réunification allemande oui
mitterrand allait moscou cole le
président bush parfois ce n'est pas
exactement le même langage il se
concerter entre eux puis finalement à la
fin il ya bien eu une position commune
là il me semble qu'on est dans le même
dans le même scénario que vous pensez
des escalades à vous écouter j'en sais
rien parce que ça dépend de ce que de ce
que veut poutine
ce qui me semble c'est que healy lui
serait très coûteux de d'attaqué et
surtout d'attaquer massivement et après
tout rien ne prouve qu'il ait une
approche rationnelle de cette question
iranienne laissez moi vous dire une
chose à propos de la finlandisation
c'est que avec les finlandais les russes
ne présentait pas que c'était le même
peuple que le peuple russe il avait un
vase la dyle effectivement peuple
ukrainien et le peuple russes c'est le
même peuple irrespect il avait un
respect profond pour les finlandais qui
s'était pas mal battu contre eux alors
que là la façon dont poutine parle de
l'ukraine démontre un mépris profond et
donc si on était une crânien on
comprendrait qu'on n'est pas très
attirés par le concept de finlandisation
égard delanoë vous pense effectivement
qu'il ya une carte européenne
aujourd'hui qui se joue
pour moi ce que j'observe si vous voulez
c'est un certain qu'il ya une rôle de
plate comme good cop en revanche on
observe une répartition des rôles de
fait qui se met en place c'est à dire
que en gros il ya deux sujets il ya le
sujet des garanties de sécurité dans la
zone euro atlantique et de la
redéfinition des architectures de
sécurité dans la zone euro atlantique ça
ça va se jouer en gros entre les russes
les américains les français rentrent est
une contribution à un moment donné le
président macro l'a évoqué hier
visiblement avec que avec vladimir
poutine mais en réalité ça va se jouer
entre les russes et les américains le
deuxième sujet c'est donc la crise en
ukraine dans as c'est minsk 2 et à la
france a une légitimité et à mon avis a
une capacité rap us est véritablement
dynamique puisque d'une part elle est
membre du format normandie avec
l'allemagne la russie et l'ukraine comme
ça été dit d'autre part quand même sur
continent duc les britanniques ont pris
le large et en kit et l'europe ça reste
la seule puissances du p5 une puissance
dotée donc lé cas une voix particulière
une légitimité particulière à s'affirmer
dans dans ce rôle là maintenant sur la
déclaration de bruno le maire en je
pense que il mine de rien il fait
référence à peut-être malgré lui mais a
dix quand même des épisodes qui sont
passés entre le jir et le rôle du
spoiler des états unis dans le cas du
format de binz 15 rappelle que le
précédent envoyé américain
kurt volker donc sur une station trump
qui travaillait était le point de
contact des russes si vous voulez sur la
question craignant régulièrement
s'illustrer par des fuites dans la
presse américaine aurait filmé tank
américain où il donne des infos qui a
réclamé un caractère confidentiel sur
les discussions en cours qui avait quand
même du sabotage de ces discussions qui
étaient régulièrement faites par les
américains et je rappelle enfin que
toujours sur la trace de mer que quand
il parle de sécurité d'intérêt
différents entre les américains et les
européens basiquement les voisins
directement des russes et si on va dans
l'escaladé notamment diplômante armes à
portée intermédiaire d'armes nucléaires
de théâtre c'est pas les américains qui
sont en premier ce sera les européens
continent européen donc à mon avis c'est
là qu'il ya des petites violences qu'il
faut néanmoins intégré mais que turque
in bad cop bad cop les emails des états
unis c'est le bad cop la france et good
cop dans cette région chrétienne bon
j'aime bien l'idée ce serait utile
peut-être mais mais il faut le dire que
le ball-trap des états unis ne menace
pas de grand chose c'est à dire que
cette langage des réponses économiques
des sanctions tout ça je n'ai pas
vraiment l'impression que poutine âme
que ça lui est
prêté il s'en fiche et ceci dit aussi le
problème que ni la france ni les états
unis et prêts vraiment à
renforcer des mots avec le pouvoir et
j'ai vraiment l'impression que une des
grandes leçons de cet épisode c'est
l'importance
de pouvoir dehors du fait qu'il faut
pouvoir
dissuader des engagements et des états
comme et
qui pourrait très bon raisons ni les
états unis ni la france cherche à faire
mais parce que bon la banque estime que
ces événements
c'est grave mais ils sont sans avoir
cette volonté il ya très peu de choses
qu'on peut faire ni les etats-unis ni la
france et dans pratiquement vous voulez
dire oui n'est pas ma tin man est
de soulager un peu j'ai l'impression que
chez poutine ya presque une fragilité
psychologique
quand je n'ai entendu parler à la
conférence de presse avec par contre
j'avais l'impression qu'ils avaient
besoin d'être soulagé parce qu'ici ils
disent y presque mais tout le monde
s'est tu as comme moi c'est pas juste et
donc peut-être il ya l'ouverture là est
peut-être macro est vraiment buffet pour
sa 2 d'essayer de jouer avec lui de la
mairie comme joe biden
oui on dit joe biden parce qu'ils se
sont parlé manifestement mnl macro et
djaïdani bon je crois que ce j'ai des
parcs aux fins de ce jeu quoique
d'études et 200 éléments de même côté
qui a très peu de différence entre ma
campagne
il ya eu manioc différents a parlé il ya
un accent différent il se sait tout à
fait normal et c'est une bonne chose
c'est de mon chose parce que il se peut
que dans cette différence entre cette
petite invention thomas camp et bagues
nous il y à un autre et aussi entre des
menus différents parlers il y à quelques
pas là germes d'une possibilité de
trouver une solution diplomatique
alors c'est très important mais je n'ai
pas vraiment l'impression que l'étude
des deux
tickets indifférent ils sont d'accord
français voilà mais que la marge de
manoeuvre est très faible à vous
entendre jacques rupnik pour revenir sur
ces accords de minsk puisque
effectivement
igor delanoë en parlait déjà ces accords
de minsk de manifestement sont sur la
table ils en ont reparlé aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron et le président
ukrainien zelensky alors c'est compliqué
parce que ce format normandie
effectivement qui permet à l'ukraine
d'être sur la table haute à la table des
négociations mais là ce que disait
effectivement igor delanoë c'est que
c'est à cause des ukrainiens que les
accords ne sont pas appliquées alors
alors qu'effectivement les ukrainiens 10
disent que c'est à cause des russes donc
en fait chacun se renvoie la balle sur
un accord finalement qui a entraîné un
cessez le feu qui n'a pas été respecté
n'est ce pas parce qu'il ya treize mille
morts et plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de blessés donc qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui
peut être
quelle est la base qu'est ce qui peut
permettre dans cet accord d'être une
base diplomatique une base de discussion
alors d'abord il ya le ya la situation
interne de l'ukraine et la politique
ukrainienne elle même on se souvient
peut-être du fait que le président
ukrainien zelensky a été élu sur l'idée
qu'il allait mettre un terme au conflit
que son prédécesseur porochenko avait la
posture martiale qu'il allait défendre
et lui allaient arrêter le conflit et
arrêter le conflit lui qui est
russophone d'ailleurs
zelensky
à l'esa signifié en gros accepter l'idée
d'une autonomie régionale pour pour le
donbass mais est donc ça ça fait partie
de ce que l'on attend comme concessions
du pouvoir ukrainien mais comment faire
de telles concessions alors que vous
avez une une incursion russe un soutien
russe aux séparatistes et ne se sont pas
retirés depuis il aurait pu faire un
geste en dire bon
nous ne nous retirons n'est ce pas notre
soutient nous arrêtons de soutenir donc
une responsabilité russe et voilà il ses
responsabilités russe et donc on est
ensuite dans un cercle vicieux où
peut-être justement le retour à la table
de négociation dans le cadre de format 2
dans le contexte que l'on a vue
actuellement peut-être que ça peut
favoriser une mémé c'est devenu plus
difficile ce qui était faisable ya
quelques années est devenu beaucoup plus
difficile quoi parce qu'il ya quand vous
avez plus de cent mille hommes de
troupes massées à votre frontières et
vous le faites sous la menace il ya donc
beaucoup d'émotion et beaucoup dé
beaucoup de craintes côté ukrainien
maintenant que vous avez créé une
situation politique qui n'est pas
favorable à ça d'une façon générale je
dirai tout ce qu'a fait poutine au cours
de ces dernières années a contribué à ce
que la russie perde l'ukraine quand il a
annexé la crimée il a perdu l'ukraine
c'est fait vous créer une situation dans
le donbass vous créez en ce moment cette
situation
de menace véritablement militaire et
tout ce que ça peut faire en ukraine
c'est susciter de scintillement
sentiment national le réflexe défensif
et ce qui était impensable il ya
quelques années c'est à dire se tourner
vers l'otan et c est devenu une priorité
il ya il ya quinze ans
un quart peut-être un tiers des
ukrainiens étaient favorables à une
entrée dans l'otan aujourd'hui peut-être
une majorité d'entre eux le l'accepterai
ce n'est pas à l'ordre du jour mais
c'est pour dire que poutine ça fait
effectivement des outils n'a contribué à
faire basculer l'ukraine dans quelque
chose qu'il prétend lui-même combattre
michel duclos et sur justement ces
accords de minsk de ils peuvent être une
base de négociation alors
qu'effectivement son désaccord qui sont
pas appliquées et chacun se renvoie la
balle ukrainiens et russes sur la
responsabilité de cette non-application
en tous les cas c'est un prétexte c'est
un point de départ il y en a pas
d'autres c'est comme ça que les
diplomates résonne il faut s'appuyer sur
sur ce qui existe sur ce qui a été agréé
je voudrais ajouter quelque chose pour
que vous compreniez bien je pense que
l'une des causes de cette crise soudaine
et à certains égards bizarre
disproportionnée et bien sûr
l'une d'elles à des facteurs
initiaux c'est le fait que le rapport de
force en ukraine avait évolué au
détriment de la russie depuis quelques
mois c'est à dire depuis que
l'administration maiden avait équipé et
entraîné les forces us crânienne kids
pad d'autres peurs avait reçu des drones
de la part de de la turquie et donc les
proxys aux russes pour utiliser les mots
peu réaliste dans le donbass était
commencé à être en difficulté et ça
c'était quelque chose sans doute de très
difficile à accepter pour poutine qui
voyait 6,6 il n'intervenait pas cette
tendance-là
susceptibles de se renforcer et devenir
un vrai danger pour
les positions qui veut dire que les
ukrainiens pour ses responsables de
cette menace quotidienne voudrais
surtout pas dire ça les ukrainiens se
défendent c'est leur droit absolu et je
pense qu'ils ont raison je pense que
s'il ne le faisait pas en plus les
russes continuerai à avancer et de leur
côté à faire évoluer le rapport de force
en leur faveur
et donc c'est pour dire que cette crise
qui apparaît largement artificielle
avait quand même un point de départ qui
explique que les deux acteurs en tous
les cas lecteurs russes avaient besoin
de bouger et c'est vrai comme l'a dit
tout à l'heure igor qui a donc deux
plans distincts il ya le plan
l'ukrainien illya le plan plus
généralement les équilibres des forces
la stabilité en europe comme on dit les
les armements mais il ya un troisième
plan qu'il faut pas oublier c'est le
facteur chinois et là moi je suis frappé
par le fait que la grande déclaration
sino russe qui a été signé à pékin au
moment de l'ouverture des des jeux
olympiques marque un progrès essentiel
dans l'alignement des deux pays sur un
certain nombre d'objectifs sur leur
vision du monde sera un appui mutuelle
mais en même temps tout laisse penser
que xi ne tient pas vraiment à ce qu'il
y ait la guerre en europe ça
déstabiliserait l'économie mondiale et
finalement ce serait pas très profitable
pour la finale donc c'est un allié
fiable ou c'est quelqu'un que l'on
révisé à dire poutine si c'était lié
c'est un allié certainement sûr mais qui
n'a pas dû encourager poutine à passer à
l'attaqué igor delanoë sur les minsk les
accords de minsk de donc vous vous dites
c'est de la responsabilité des russes
finalement qu'ils soient pas appliquer
ces accords et on pourrait les remettre
sur la table aujourd'hui dans la
responsabilité seront partagés c'est à
dire que effectivement sur le volet
militaire les russes ont clairement pas
aidé en revanche le volet politique la
balle est dans le camp des ukrainiens de
départ faut quand même rappeler que ces
accords du monde ce que 2 reflète un
rapport de force totalement défavorables
à l'ukraine puisqu'ils sont signés au
lendemain d'une débâcle militaire de
l'armée chrétienne dans ton las depuis
toujours votre père le battait anciens
accords qui fatalement vous êtes
défavorable donc cet accord est très
défavorables à l'ukraine il est
favorable aux intérêts russes sarr fait
un rapport de force qui est ce qu'il
était et aujourd'hui c'est une réalité
que les ukrainiens fait valoir revisité
c'est à dire que il considère que ces
accords sont une menace la sécurité
nationale très récemment pas plus tard
qu'il ya quelques jours des déclarations
ont été faites par monsieur coulibaly
les affaires étrangères ukrainien ainsi
que par le secrétaire général du conseil
de sécurité ukrainiens au dessus danilov
qui d'habitude ne se prononcent jamais
et tous deux disent et si on en met en
oeuvre ces accords il y aura le chaos en
ukraine
conséquence du crime peut être pas de
ces accords ils ne peuvent pas le faire
pour un tas de raisons il faut faire une
réforme constitutionnelle qui suppose
d'octroyer donc un statut spécial audace
dono à donetsk est lougansk une amnistie
de mener ensuite des élections tant
basse et in fine et ultime mans les
ukrainiens recouvriront la souveraineté
sur la portion de frontières qui partage
avec la russie dans d'aulas évidemment
le ça ne leur convient pas ils veulent
d'abord encourir la souveraineté
qu'ensuite le processus se déroule c'est
pas comme ça que les ados dialogue de
sourds pardonnez moi un certain rythme
sourd mais cela dit pour répondre à
votre question ça reste la seule base
aujourd'hui concevable il viable et
c'était très bien rappelé au président
macron c'est le seul cadre aujourd'hui
légitime pour éviter une conflagration
et résoudre résoudre ce conflit donc
comment on peut y arriver qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui qui n'a pas
marché depuis maintenant en 2015 et bien
ce serait effectivement que peut-être
les français les allemands qui jusqu'à
présent donc quand même l'impression
d'avoir endossé la posture moralement de
l'ukraine se décide à utiliser quand
même certains le lien qu'ils ont pour
que les ukrainiens se mettent enfin à
mettre en oeuvre ces accords monsieur
maquereau en chef a rappelé qu' à une
tranche de 1 milliard 2 qui a été
débloqué par l'union européenne pour
l'ukraine que alstom va signer des
contrats en ukraine ça a été rappelé
aussi mine de rien que la france
contribuer au réarmement et craignent
alors réarmement à dramatiser le terme
et il racontera pour des des vedettes si
vous voulez qu'ils étaient signées par
les banques en fait vous poussez les
ukrainiens à faire des concessions sur
les accords d minsk ce sont des leviers
j'ose espérer que remplaçant servir le
cas échéant pas leur faire comprendre
que c'est à eux de faire aussi un bout
de chemin sur le volet politique insiste
sur l'aspect tous les politiques pour
débloquer la situation les présidents
sont réunis au format normandie à paris
en décembre 2019 une feuille de route
qui a été réactualisé ya rien qui a été
fait depuis en devant brive et
checkpoint très peu été ouvert une des
rares échanges de prisonniers ça n'a pas
eu une en q les armes lourdes n'ont pas
été totalement retiré quelle ligne de
contact ça ce sont des premiers pas qui
doivent être faits évidemment les
ukrainiens et les séparatistes doivent
le faire des deux côtés
mais pour l'instant on va dire qu'on a
nos même stade qu'en 2019 marquant c'est
une bonne nouvelle que cette formation
réunit déjà demain au niveau des
conseillers politiques manifestement les
prochains jours pourquoi pas au niveau
des chefs d'état jacques rupnik ça veut
dire qu'on va a demandé à l'ukraine de
faire des concessions fin on en est un
petit peu là aujourd'hui vous avez
certes impression oui enfin on demande à
faire venir poutine on ne sait pas ce
qui l'a mis sur la table dans cet
entretien avec emmanuel macron
manifestement il dit qu' il n'y a pas il
n'a pas parlé de désescalade alors que
modèle macron a parlé de désescalade il
a même j'ai vu que la russie a envoyé
six navires de guerre en mer noire donc
du côté de la meilleure poutine on en
est pas vraiment aux concessions en
revanche on va demander des concessions
aux ukrainiens oui c'est vrai ça dans le
cadre de la négociation c'est dire que
les concessions ensuite son doivent être
réciproque
on peut pas de manquer ce que la russie
va mettre sur la table
d escalade militaire déjà et
retrait de son soutien aux
séparatistes du donbass il accepterait
farrell va pas pas du jour au lendemain
mais en échange de la perspective
d'une évolution vers ce qui pourrait
être une autonomie régionale moi je
pense que l'intégrité territoriale de
l'ukraine à long terme n'est viable que
s'il ya une autonomie régionale
pas seulement d'ailleurs pour le donbass
pour d'autres de ses programmes oui le
seul pour cette province et d'ailleurs
décentralisation enfin autonomie
régionale l'ecosse au sein du royaume
uni ces exemples sont condition que
l'ukraine fois souveraine se trouvent
parce que mes très vives autonomie ça
veut peut-être dire aussi contrôler de
l'extérieur il mais voilà donc
quand on est quand on est en situation
de faiblesse on ne veut pas lâcher le
pouvoir central n'est ce pas un
décentralisation généralement c'est dans
un climat de confiance et c'est à ça que
sert la diplomatie est-ce qu'on peut
rétablir un minimum peut-être pas de
confiance est un bien grand mot mais au
moins de détente d escalade militaire en
échange de deux concessions politiques
je ne vois pas l'alternative du point de
vue de poutine un excellent combat ça
serait ça la perspective invasion de
l'ukraine non ou alors les akans de mise
mais très favorable à la russie ou au
détriment de l'ukraine non je ne pense
pas l'autre option l'option militaire
alors si on pense que l'option
diplomatique minsk
normandie que tout ça n'est pas
suffisant alors l'option militaire c'est
de quoi annexé cette partie du sud est
de l'ukraine à la russie et faire une
continuité territoriale entre la crimée
et la russie mais si les russes avaient
voulu le faire il aurait pu le faire en
2014 personne ne s'y serait personne
n'avait les moyens de s'y opposer bien
vous n'y croyez vous n'y croyez pas je
n'y crois enfin je je je pense que le
coup alors là cette fois ci pour pour la
russie serait énorme je parle pas du
coût sanctions et non le coup en sommes
le coup disons ce serait un bourbier
militaire
dans lequel je ne vois pas l'intérêt de
s'engager michel duclos sur ces accords
de minsk justement est ce que au final
on a ce qui ce qui est en train d'être
discuté en ce moment ce sont des accords
de miss très favorable à la russie et
finalement des grandes concessions du
côté de l'ukraine est ce que c'est ça ce
qu'ils ont la table honnêtement je ne
crois pas parce que je crois que dans
cette crise les ukrainiens ont quand
même gagné beaucoup de beaucoup de
soutien et que au fond poutine a
déployer le très grand jeu là plus de
cent mille hommes
c'est quoi c'est considérable pour un
objectif qui ne peut être que limitée et
donc contrairement à ce que beaucoup de
gens disent ça m'a n'est pas si forte
que cela si on met une sacrée pression
militaire de saint louis se fait une
très grande pression militaire mais
macron est un homme très réaliste et je
suis certain que quand il dit que les
les ukrainiens doit faire des
concessions il entend par là que ces
concessions doivent avoir des
contreparties russe vous pensez que
cette aventure de mythes qui peut être
d'un accord d'égal à égal c'est à dire
oui je les russes et les ukrainiens gêné
je pense qu'il faut pas raisonner en
termes de mise en oeuvre point par point
de tous les éléments de l'accord de nice
mais il peut y avoir des éléments il
peut y avoir un accord
disons à moitié de ce qui est prévu par
par minsk est donc là ça veut dire des
concessions de part et d'autre ça veut
dire que les russes relâche la pression
sur le dombass mike fisher king vous y
croyez vous à des concessions de part et
d'autre dans le cadre de l'accord de
minsk et finalement est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils on va vers une désescalade
si on va vers des accolades j'espère
bien je ne sais pas si ça va se passer
mais quand je regarde les écoles de
minsk donc tout ça complique s'est
contracté que des détails je vois ça me
donne raison à aspirer parce que dans
tous ses détails ja si on veut une
désescalade il ya de quoi il des excuses
qu'on peut ferrière des mécanismes ya
des opportunités pour donner des
chiffres des échanges de feu des
quiproquos
que qui peut-être vont suffire à
donner satisfaction c'était dans tous
ses détails on peut trouver des
solutions il vous était petit militant
non non je ne rêve pas du tout mais il
ya la possibilité
c'est pour ça que j'applaudis débat
tentative de mac ans et je crois qu'il a
raison que une quille est très peu de
chance des économies sont des sols base
de départ à qui existe et s'il ya
vraiment intérêt d escalade etc
en question parce que je ne vois pas
mais si on a il ya dedans des moyens de
trouver des solutions de trouver des
quiproquos qui monte permettra à la
russie a sauvé la face aussi à aden
depuis quand ces deux-là n'osons penser
qu'il y aura une désescalade un an douar
ans on n'a plus le temps
de ce que je pense que là c'est que pour
l'instant évidemment la russie continue
de garder les deux fers au feu c'est
bien et continue maintenir le dialogue
évidemment avec les européens à travers
le président lacrampe et avec les
américains il se passe beaucoup de
choses avec les américains on n'a pas
parlé mais en même temps évidemment elle
continue de maintenir de brandir
d'utilitaires de déployer des troupes le
dispositif est encore en cours de
constitution et parler de ce qui se
passe en mer noire il ya aussi des
choses pour méditerranée afin évidemment
de merci en tout cas merci beaucoup
michel duclos merci igor delanoë merci
beaucoup michael churchill merci à vous
et jacques rupnik